aujourd'hui dans les médias est un sujet
qui a été commentée par tous je veux
parler bien sûr de patrick bruel
alors toutes les chaînes info en eau par
les regarder on a fait une compile tout
le monde a parlé que de ça aujourd'hui
patrick bruel entendu dans une affaire
d'exhibition sexuelle présumée l'artiste
est sous le coup d'une enquête
préliminaire une esthéticienne dénonce
un comportement déplacé de sa part free
bruel aurait tenu des propos laissant
entendre clairement qu'il attendait une
prestation à caractère sexuel qu'il
aurait refusée malgré l'insistance de
l'artiste la jeune femme n'a pas porté
plainte mais elle a souhaité laisser une
trace au cas où d'autres victimes se
ferait connaître patrick bruel a donc
été entendu dimanche sous le régime de
l'audition libre par les gendarmes de
châlons en champagne où il se produisait
dimanche soir alors tout le monde a
parlé que de ça aujourd'hui c'est est
sorti hier dans le parisien faut
rappeler un patrick bruel ses dix neuf
albums 15 millions d'albums vendus 5
disques placé en tête des ventes en
france 3 mis plus de 3 millions
d'entrées pour le prénom 27
participation aux [ __ ] patrie bref
c'est quelqu'un qui n'ait jamais eu
aucun problème dans sa carrière dans sa
vie privée dans cette voie là on n'a
jamais fait parler lui et eux il ya une
information qui révélé hier soir par le
parisien
voilà le 9 août dernier patrick bruel
donné un concert à ajaccio le chanteur a
bénéficié d'un massage la part d'une
jeune et esthéticienne dans sa loge
avant le concert voilà et la jeune femme
l'accuse d'avoir eu un comportement
inapproprié
avec elle lors d'un massage alors depuis
la mi août le parquet d'ajaccio a ouvert
une enquête préliminaire pour
exhibitions sexuelles et harcèlement
sexuel
voilà il faut savoir que la jeune femme
n'a pas déposé plainte mais a souhaité
ainsi laissé une trace au cas où
d'autres victimes présumées se
manifesterait c'est ce qu'elle a
d'ailleurs selon le parisien patrick
bruel auraient été entendus dimanche
histoire sous le régime de l'audition
libre par les gendarmes à châlons en
champagne où il venait se produire et
eric bouillard le procureur de la
république d'ajaccio s'est exprimé sur
bfm tv il est revenu sur les faits qui
ont été reprochés à patrick bruel cette
prestation a duré quelques minutes
pendant lesquelles elle a ressenti un
vrai malaise qu'elle n'ose exprimer
tous sous plusieurs formes on part une
lumière qui était évidemment faible une
porte qui était fermée un non respect
des protocoles qu'elle al'habitude
qu'ils aient quand elle a cinq clients
et notamment le refus au monsieur bruel
de romaine de mettre les vêtements qu'il
portait qui permettait de cacher sa
nullité on sait où elle a été entendue
hier et il a nié les faits qui lui
étaient reprochés
alors il faut savoir que c'est le
procureur a donc forcément il est
instruit il prêche pour sa paroisse st
forcément patrick bruel a démenti bien
entendu il expliqué est resté nu pendant
le massage se portant lorsqu'il s'est
mis sur le dos et se seraient couverts
d'une serviette
il a ajouté nous avoir une n'avoir
jamais eu d'intention sexuelle à l'égard
de la jeune femme contrairement à ce qu
elle affirmerait ses proches et son
avocat ne se sont pas exprimés dans les
médias sur les réseaux sociaux le
chanteur s'est muré dans le silence
également
et sachez qu'il a annulé aujourd'hui un
voyage au canada où il devait faire la
promotion de sa tournée alors selon nos
informations géraldine je crois que
c'est vous qui avez les informations on
a contacté une employée du spa c'est
valérie bénaïm d'ailleurs et qu'est ce
qui à la rédaction on a effectivement
contacté le seul le spa de l'hôtel et
une des employés une des collègues delà
de la jeune femme nous a donné quelques
informations alors selon elle évidemment
ça c'est ça mais il remet pas en cause
la parole de la jeune fille mais elle
elle dit que
elle aurait vu l'esthéticienne juste
après qu'elle ait masse et patrick bruel
que cet esthétisme ne se serait plaint
de rien n'aurait rien dit à la suite de
ce massage qu'elle était plutôt même
contente après le passage dans la loge
dans ce cas-là assister au concert au
dessus et en dessous est elle assiste
effectivement avec d'autres camarades
howell massages à prix exact alors la
personne doit donc aurait vu
l'esthéticienne donc après avoir massé
par google est patrick bruel elle l'a
dit aussi qu'il aurait toujours été très
charmant il n'aurait jamais eu de
problème avec lui donc c'est vrai que
moi dans cette affaire ont remis en
cause ni ce que dit la jeune femme
voilà la raison de son innocence et
intégrée élise la défense de patrick
juste c'est vrai que ça a été un bis
faire le mans
moi je le vois encore dans l'es4 infos
du jour il y avait patrick bruel sinon
dans le monde 1 qui est quand même un
journal très sérieux et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ça a été un déferlement
partout bf hébreu blasé jour déferlement
balawi semer ses salons pour les autres
problèmes ces déferlements un mot tu
provoques un déferlement
voilà ça notre première palmade on l'a
vu il a été il a été blanchi juste après
pierre palmade alors que ça avait été
aussi partout et on avait des alertes
toute la journée concernant père pal mal
et son affaire le deux jours après il
avait été blanchi on a eu beaucoup moins
d' alerte alors bon je vous dis on ne
remet jamais on ne remet pas en cause ce
qu'a dit cette jeune femme voilà et
mélangez pas dû être le fait de pas
prendre à la légère ce que dit une femme
à propos d'une agression sexuelle parce
qu'on sait que par le passé c'était pas
pris au sérieux ces allégations mais en
même temps c'est pas seulement une
déferlement c'est qu'il ya des journaux
qui distille des petites informations
venimeuse alors qu'ils n'ont aucune
information personnelle c'est sûr voilà
et personne ne sait rien et quand même
il ya des trucs un peu à charge contre
bruel moi je trouve et sur les réseaux
sociaux ça a été mon cheveu surgit a été
vraiment scandaleux et calomnieux
galopante
ça c'est terrible il était en effet la
méchanceté tweet on a on a reçu des
alertes vous avez reçu des verts moi
j'ai eu des appels toute la journée
le personne qu'est ce qui se passe avec
patrick bruel qu'est-ce qui a eu et
patrick guat quel est le dossier club
fribourg et louis giraldi alors on sait
pas si ce sont des secousses poste
balances ton port parce qu'il ya quand
même quelque chose moi je trouve pour le
coude acda c'est malsain
en revanche moi ce que je voudrais dire
aux jeunes femmes qui nous regardent
c'est que quand on doit faire un malaise
enfin quand on doit faire un massage et
que le protocole n'est pas respectée on
a droit de sortir quand on trouve que la
lumière est tamisée on
sortir on a droit de dire non on a droit
de dire attention non non non non alors
moi dans manon lala 2008 ont atteint je
vous arrête de produire complètement non
souple et là je vous arrête de petites
choses vous êtes en loges étaient quatre
breaks extrêmement connue c'est je peux
vous dire il faut avoir la jeune femme
elle peut se sentir mal à l'aise dessus
après voilà non arrêté l'alchimie des
les femmes on est en train de leur dire
de prenez dans un mois attendez l'était
pas ce qui aura pas trop de monde c est
un procès dans un mois comme ça il y
aura beaucoup d'âmes procès mais
franchement match sauvées mais la
retraite lalalalalala géraldine gens
trouvent mauvaise fois excusez moi mais
n'aurait pas mangé de beaucoup basse on
a droit de dire non aux femmes à dire
nous apprennent aux femmes d'aller voir
la maudite je suis désolé c'est
extrêmement compliqué de dire non à la
21 l'ont arrêté c'est la notoriété pas
dire que toutes les familles des
victimes sous influence
il avait le temps d'attendre la suite de
l' enquête mais c'est bien sûr vu le
charme de bruel vu sa notoriété sur tout
le talent de la jirama vegas de ne pas
provoquer de scandale
elle est quand même un chrono tél donc
c'est compliqué c'est continue à nous ce
qu'on voulait c'est que tout le monde
s'est jeté sur l'information
c'est incroyable même les médias les
plus sérieux voilà et c'est vrai que
c'est incroyable dès qu'un petit tiens
voilà il y aurait une petite c2 breizh
ça devient ça devient surtout qu'en plus
dans ce cas précis c'est d'autant plus
bizarre c'est même pas bizarre mais
c'est d'autant plus gênant parce qu'
elle n'a pas déposé plainte
elle n'a même pas voulu déposer dans des
doc c'est bizarre que ce soit repris par
kevala c'est ce que la jeune fille la
pauvre elle a même pas donné la peine
d'artistes elle n'a pas déposé plainte
la pause 40 faut bien sûr le droit vers
la technique des états unis eh bien tu
demandes du feu à une femme il ya deux
flics qui arrivent et huttes aux toits
en tôle non agression sexuelle et a
demandé würm et je vous dit elle
l ong dire à la peau mais si la jeune
fille elle n'a pas déposé plainte donc
c'est une info qui est sorti même elle
je suis même pas sûr qu'elle voulait que
ça fasse un tel ramdam joli jeu
certainement pas sûr du tout je pense
que même l salon merde je vous dis c'est
possible aussi que ça l'ambiance que ce
cette histoire voilà face à un tel raz
fait d'ailleurs comme c'est parole
contre parole
c'est normalement donc le procureur qui
décidera de la suite de la faire et il
peut dire que il n'y a pas assez de
matière pour créer une instruction mais
pas le dossard et bien oui
mais oui mais oui mais oui mais là là là
de mine de rien l'image de patrice morel
valls a dit cette jeune fille mine de
rien vous allez voir elle ne veut pas
dire ah bah c'est la jeune fille elle
peut être perturbé pendant longtemps
donc si vous vous flinguer les
responsables un gay deux personnes et
jean-michel non mais c'est pour ça c'est
pas parce qu'il n'y a pas qu'elle n'a
pas porté pas ne pliera pas un procès
parce que le substitut procureur peut
évidemment décidé de se porter de pas de
porte la parole de la jeune fille qui
n'a pas voulu parler mais voilà et de
décider qui aurait d'instruction et un
procès si les faits sont suffisamment
importants je n'ai pas dit que ça mais
ce problème c'est qu'on arrivait un
basculement aujourd'hui dans le temps
les victimes
la parole des victimes n'étaient pas
audibles maintenant la parole des
présumés innocents n'est plus écouté
donc c'était une émission jugée avant
avant l'heure cette catastrophe
mais quand on voit que quelqu'un de pas
très connu les médias s'en emparent tout
ceci nous imaginer le nom et leur nom de
patrick bruel c'était impossible que ça
passe sous silence vous je le déplore
mais c'est impossible mais oui mais
est-ce qu est ce qu elle voulait ça la
jeune fille est ce que n'oublions pas
que nous parlons que de comportement
soit disant oui alors aujourd'hui donc
je vous le dis donc patrick bruel qui
l'aurait décaler sa tournée au canada
on n'a pas réussi bien sûr à le joindre
patrick bruel ou aujourd'hui parce que
ils vivent bien sûr ne veut pas
s'exprimer sur cette affaire
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui voilà on
attend il ya le procureur quand même qui
s'est exprimé sur bfm tv est ce que vous
trouvez vous normal que le procureur
peut puisse s'exprimer comme ça sur une
chaîne d'info pour expliquer la faire
tout de suite où il aurait dû attendre
eric naulleau moi je trouve que dans
cette affaire plus personne ne contrôle
rien que ça prend tout de suite des
proportions incroyables avec très peu
d'informations aient beaucoup à charge
contre bruel trouve ça un peu
disproportionné pour le pour le pour le
moment après il faut pas non plus
minimiser les effets moi je prends au
sérieux ce que dix sept jeunes femmes
mais moi j'ai l'impression que elle même
elle est dépassé par la tournure des
événements qui se seraient plaints moi
j'appelle ça du respect faut respecter
la jeune fille faut respecter patrie
globale c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné vous ruiner la vie de deux
personnes d'un couffin sens je sais pas
moi je trouve ça ignoble tamise ça alors
ça il ya eu foule dit c'est pas la
première fois que les médias les médias
sortent des informations comme celles ci
qui visaient des stars on en a parlé
pierre palmade le 11 avril a été accusé
de viol la réalité était bien différente
ensuite car il s'agissait d'une fausse
accusation
il ya eu gérard depardieu aussi cette
affaire a été classée sans suite il ya
une et marc après plusieurs polémiques
la plainte a finalement été classée sans
suite également au mois d'août c'est
vrai que ça a jalonné comme ça cette
année
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui patrick
bruel qui est un garçon qui n'a jamais
eu aucun problème on n'a jamais eu à
entendre
on n'a jamais entendu un truc sur
patrick bruel aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
on se met à sa place et on se dit autant
la place de jeunes filles comptant la
place de patrick bruel
aujourd'hui de revivre des moments assez
compliqué il annule sa tournée parce
qu'il n'a pas envie de se retrouver nez
journée si vous le mercure que ça
profite pas de sa promotion
voilà et du coup les gens considèrent ce
que le fait qu'il ait abandonné sa
tournée comme un aveu de culpabilité ça
c'est terrible on va s'en sortir
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
laisser des traces une affaire comme ça
ou bien est-ce que vous pensez que ça va
ça va passer puisque voilà c'est là je
serai comme dernière soirée la jeune
fille n'a pas porté plainte
voilà c est qu est ce qu est ce que vous
pensez que ça va laisser des traces en
moi je penserai laissé des traces c'est
comme une tâche que nous n'arriverons
jamais à nettoyer cette faire
disparaître quand c'est parole contre
parole
y a pas de train castaldi bah écoutez
moi je suis embêté parce que soit il
s'est passé quelque chose de grave
non mais on n'est pas rentré là bas
nommé sébacées le problème mais en fait
tu n'y arrives pas sans rien que là on
sait rien oui on sait rien ça bref c'est
qu'on parle avec une chose qui n'a pas
eu aucun lyon on n'en sait rien donc
effectivement je pense qu'elle est les
gens j'espère que laisse ici tout est
prouvé qu'il y avait ici rien passé
espère que patrick sera pas entachée
c'est une grande vedette jamie il a fait
parler de lui pour ces choses-là
donc normalement j'ai couru sur les
réseaux sociaux turna mais je suis
d'accord l'affairé à chaud et j'espère
qu'il ira pas de suite mais c'est vrai
que moi ce qui me sidère c'est que il
n'y a pas d'affaires en fait n hésitez
pas à faire une enquête
bon d'accord il n'y a pas d'affaires oui
il n'ya pas de paye a pas de haine à
faire aujourd'hui personne n'a porté
plainte et on a que des on dit c'est ça
c'est terrible de voir le procureur ces
situations mais moi je suis très embêté
parce qu'il fait commencer cette jeune
femme apparemment à l'appât de envie de
donner suite patrick bruel semble être
effectivement en dehors de tout ça et
c'est très dommageable que des gens
parlent à tort et à travers et que et
l'un et l'autre est évidemment plus pour
patrick moi j'aime beaucoup
soit entachée et j'espère que ça restera
pas effectivement voilà géraldine non
mais moi je pense un chien peu perturbé
parce que je trouve qu'en fait on vit
une drôle d'époque
je sais pas comment les hommes vont
faire pour séduire les femmes comment ça
va se passer il va falloir que marlène
schiappa soit là pour valider
moore pas lourd si c'est la séduction je
vous saut à chaque fois sur ce sujet oui
nous centrer à fleur d'eau qu'american
gestion c'est exactement ce que dit jean
marie bigard c'est que aux états unis
aujourd'hui les hommes ne monte pas dans
les ascenseurs avec les femmes
oui mais que géraldine avoir un profond
pouvez vous pouvez comprendre aussi
qu'il ya eu des grosses dérives mais
bien vous jamais été dénoncées pendant
des années dans ça en disant ça je ne
sais pas fâché pas je suis évidemment
très par les féminicides outré par les
violences faites aux femmes
mais je pense qu'il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui dans les rapports homme
femme et je pense qu'aujourd'hui si une
femme et un homme est séduit par une
femme
elle a le droit de manger pas à la femme
elle a droit de dire nous et un râteau
en fait ce n'est pas pénalement la
droite donne un râteau un homme est allé
dire des dégagements n'est pas intéressé
aujourd'hui va ça s'est tout de suite
harcèlement est passé d'un extrême dans
l'autre c'est simplement mais eric a
raison c'est une tâche penser qu'à la
chaire une belle robe blanche bien ça
reste quoi ouais c'est à dire que quoi
qu'il arrive dans dix ans dira mais
n'avait pas été compromis dans un truc
de massage ça c'est terrible mais enfin
j'ai remarqué que le problème s'est
imaginé je sais pas on va en boîte de
nuit ont fait une rencontre ont fait qu
il se passe ce qui se passe tout s'est
bien passé vendre clairement ya rien là
personne et bien je me suis fait ou de
hanouna ou castaldi jean michel n
importe quand je voulais que cette année
mais qu'est ce que je fais moi imaginez
ma déjà vous vous l'avez pas vu non j'ai
pas vu mais non mais c'est grave
tout à coup aujourd'hui on a une
relation avec une femme consentante ou
s'est bien passée et après parce qu'on
est connue elle peut les porter plainte
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire dire quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire qu'est-ce qu'on
va dire bah il faudrait que
l'instruction soit mené très rapidement
comme ça a été le cas avec pierre
palmade ou avec neymar ou les affaires
étaient jugés en quinze jours du coup le
feu s'éteint assez rapidement ce qu'il
faut pas que les braises continue à
rouler comme ça que le feu prenne corps
alors je voudrais dire moi j'espère
qu'il aura en tout cas s'il se trouve
que voilà cette affaire est classée
j'espère qu'il aura autant d'articles
nous est arrivé aussi on s'en rappelle
avec la ferme du coup de fil ou après on
a appris que coup de fil en fait est que
la plainte était fausse et que c'était
un faux seins faux d'appel ex tout tout
ça avait été monté de toutes pièces
il y avait eu beaucoup d'articles sur la
présence birth du roi là et sur les
articles sur sur sur le fait que c'était
tout était fou on en a vu beaucoup moins
donc c'est réussi
durban quand cette archive et on
archives jamais les droits de réponse
c'est pour ça que à l'infini vous avez
des conneries quand on ressort des
dossiers c'est un vrai drame ça